tras el último tiroteo en texas donde
una adolescente de 18 años abrió fuego
en una escuela primaria
el presidente joe biden llamó a los
estadounidenses a enfrentarse al
poderoso lobby pro armas como el que
lidera la asociación nacional del rifle
porque estamos dispuestos a vivir con
esta carnicería porque seguimos
permitiendo que esto suceda en el nombre
de dios donde está nuestra columna
vertebral para tener el coraje de
enfrentarlo y hacer frente a los grupos
de presión es hora de convertir este
dolor en acción para cada padre para
cada ciudadano de este país tenemos que
dejarlo claro a cada funcionario electo
en este país
la escuela primaria robe epicentro del
ataque da clases a más de 500 alumnos en
su mayoría hispanos y económicamente
desfavorecidos de segundo a cuarto grado
este fue un evento trágico y sin sentido
mi corazón se rompió nuestros corazones
pensamientos y oraciones están con todas
nuestras familias
el atacante que ocasionó uno de los
tiroteos más mortíferos de los últimos
tiempos en una escuela murió por
disparos de la policía lo ocurrido en
texas recuerda otros hechos similares en
el país en 2018 en parkland florida 14
estudiantes de secundaria y 3 adultos
murieron en un tiroteo y en 2012 en
connecticut en la escuela sandy hook
fallecieron 20 niños y 6 miembros del
personal según cifras oficiales en 2020
hubo 19 mil 350 homicidios por armas de
fuego del país un aumento del 35% con
respecto a 2019 pero poco se ha podido
hacer contra el lobby de armas en eeuu
la casa blanca ordenó que las banderas
ondearán a media asta en señal de duelo
por las víctimas